While you're in an interview, remember that it's not only important...
...that you answer your questions well but then you ask great questions.
Hiring managers are looking for candidates that are engaged in their field...
...and have taken the time to do research on their company.
What is it about their company that attracts you?
Why do you want to work there over the competition?
Remember that the interview is the time to ask questions that will affect your ultimate decision.
Find out what the demands and expectations are of the position.
And don't forget to ask about the company culture.
If you are a social butterfly at the office,...
...you may want to know if the company has a lot of team building activities throughout the year.
Is there a company softball team?
Do the employees socialize after work hours...
...or do most of them go straight home to their families?
Depending on where you are in life, you may prefer certain social environments over others.
Most importantly, prioritize your questions and try to avoid taking over the interview.
Let the interviewer conduct the session,...
...but be prepared when they ask you if you have any questions.
Inquiring about key components of the job will help you make an informed decision...
...on whether this company is a good fit for you,...
...and will show the employer that you are serious about the position.
For thousands of how to and advice videos on any topic, visit monkeysee.com.